[Music]
thus it is postulated that it is another
consciousness which makes them sacred or
which knows and wills them as duties the
first holds to pure Duty and different
all specific content and duty is only
this indifference towards such content
the other however contains the equally
essential relation to doing and to the
necessity of the specific content since
for this other duties mean specific
duties the content is such as equally
essential as the form which makes the
content to duty this consciousness is
consequently one in which Universal and
particular are simply one and it's
notion is therefore the same as the
notion of the harmony of morality and
happiness for this antithesis equally
expresses the separation of the self
equal moral consciousness from that
actuality which is manifold being
conflicts with the simple essential
nature of Duty well however the first
posture that expresses the harmony of
morality in nature is a harmony that
simply is because in it nature is the
negative aspect of self consciousness is
the moment of being this implicit
harmony on the other hand is now
essentially posited as consciousness for
what simply is now has the form of the
content of duty or is the determinant
'no sin the determinate duty the
implicit harmony is thus the unity of
what our simple essentiality is
essential ''tis of thought and are
therefore only in a consciousness this
is then henceforth a master and ruler of
the world who brings about the harmony
of morality and happiness and at the
same time sanctifies duties in their
multiplicity this last means this much
that for the consciousness of pure Duty
the determinate or specific Duty cannot
straightaway be sacred but because of
specific duty on account of the actual
doing which is a specific action is
likewise necessary its necessity falls
outside of that consciousness into
another consciousness which thus
mediates or brings together the specific
and the pure Duty and is the reason why
the former also has validity
paragraph 606 picks up with this
question that has been raised by the
previous paragraphs that I've got here
what makes the multiple duties sacred or
holy high leaked them it's a verb that
Hagel uses here for making sacred and
why is he raising this question well
because we've got this opposition
between sort of a pure moral
consciousness of Duty or prick'd as such
and then we have a much more reality
based of erch lika way of approaching
things which recognizes that we have a
myriad of multiple specific duties that
are based on these specific things that
we encounter in in our lives what it is
that we're actually engaged with it's
never the case that you are doing pure
duty in and of itself in the ways in
which you act in the real world so he
says it's postulated notice that now we
have yet another postulation taking
place that is a placing out in front of
ourselves not you know with any absolute
foundation but saying this has to be
there right it's postulated it is
another consciousness which makes them
the multiple duties sacred or which
knows and wills them as duties I'm going
to fast forward a little bit Hegel is
going to talk at the end of this about a
master and ruler of the world and you
might say okay well that's the one who's
actually willing and knowing and perhaps
even doing I can't that's not going to
work for the doing of the specific
duties on the other hand that other
consciousness that is also us as the
moral consciousness so bringing these
two together is going to be quite a task
so he says the first holds two pure Duty
right we've got this moral consciousness
that understand
pure duty and he says it's indifferent
to all specific content
dooty is dooty is dooty don't worry
about these specifics about should the
shopkeeper pay you know pay his
employees well or have a good price
simply because he's got this sort of
shop like you know he's making watches
or fixing Apple products or something
like that right it's not the specific
content he says duty is only this
indifference towards such content
why would duty be indifference towards
content well this is something that is
particularly important to the very
notion of duty it's supposed to be
transferable from domain to domain to
domain so if we have a duty of justice
you can say it's nice that it has to do
with jelly beans over here and watches
over here and the amount of time that
you're giving to each person on a
television program here but in a certain
sense it doesn't really matter what the
justice is about right so he goes on and
he says the other the other
consciousness contains the equally
notice this key-term equally essential
relation to doing to making something
happen to taking these ideals of duty
and putting them into reality and he
says and to the necessity of the
specific content specific content
matters here so he says for this other
duties mean specific duties it does
matter whether I'm churning butter or
churning out videos it does matter
whether I am helping an old lady across
the street or stealing you know from
from the rich to give to the poor pick
pick whatever you want right so he goes
on and he says for this other these
duties mean specific duties the content
is such is equally essential as the form
which makes the content a duty notice
the interplay between content and form
the form is that of pure duty but it's
being applied to a particular content
and
that matters here very much so he goes
on he says this consciousness now which
consciousness is he talking about let's
follow the the text and we'll see is
consequently one in which Universal in
particular are simply one and it's
notion is therefore the same as the
notion of the harmony of morality and
Happiness so we're dealing with this
other consciousness which we may be
tempted to read as simply being the same
as this other moral consciousness
concerned with the particulars but it's
more complicated than that because this
is a consciousness which is the notion
the McGriff the concept the dialectical
advance in this case right and it's
connected with this postulated harmony
that we've already talked about in the
previous paragraphs between morality and
happiness
there is a conflict there between
morality and happiness we see many
people acting morally who don't wind up
being happy we see many people acting
immorally who wind up being quite happy
at least in an earthly worldly sense of
glue or glue Klee kite which is what
Hegel has been using here as his term so
he says there we go
for this antithesis equally expresses
the separation of the self equal self
equivalent right subsc like moral
consciousness from that actuality which
is manifold being conflicts with a
simple essential nature of duty so we
have thus antithesis here between two
different moral consciousnesses which
are supposed to be united in one single
moral consciousness one way to
understand that is through this
postulated harmony so we've got two
postulates in play here right Annie says
this antithesis equally expresses this
separation right well however the first
postulate expresses the harmony of
morality in nature as a harmony that
simply is
because in it nature is the negative
aspect of self-consciousness is the
moment of being this complicit harmony
is on the other hand essentially posited
as consciousness and this is well worth
dwelling on when we're talking about
these antitheses or contradictions
between whether it's conceived of as
morality and Happiness morality and
nature the pure will and the conditioned
will that has impulses drives
inclinations any of those sorts of
things where is this this problem posed
is it out there you might say in nature
waiting for us to discover it no it's
not out there in nature as such like you
know discovering how gravity works or
any other physical phenomena like that
because it has to do with moral
consciousness it's within us to discover
and it is discovered through human
experience and reflection upon that so
on the one hand it does connect up with
the world or the universe as we might
consider it but it's not something of a
world that does not include rational
beings as already centres within that
world in a way you could say that this
entire conflict between morality and
whatever else is it's going to be can
only matter for a rational being so he
goes on and he says what it simply is
now has the form of the content of duty
or the determinate nests in the
determinate Duty so this implicit
harmony says is the unity of water
simple essentiality x' and therefore are
only in a consciousness now he brings in
this master and ruler of the world so
this is another consciousness this is
the way the other consciousness is being
revealed to us this master and ruler of
the world who brings about the harmony
of morality and happiness and at the
same time sanctifies duties in their
multiplicity now is that us or
we the master and the you know what else
the master and ruler of the world
reconciling these if not antithesis
certainly opposition's between morality
and happiness no clearly not right we
can maybe carry that out in our thought
but a lot of that is going to be
sophisms this is a real problem this is
a genuine issue here so what is this
consciousness that's being postulated as
the ruler of the world
well you know Kant thought that you had
to assume that the world was set up in
such a way that you could postulate a
harmony between morality and Happiness
he actually uses that as what's called
the moral proof of God's existence so he
says this last what's the last
sanctifying duties in their multiplicity
means this much that for the
consciousness of pure duty the
determinate or specific Duty cannot
straightaway be sacred cannot be sacred
just by being a specific Duty has to be
connected back to this conception of
duty there has to be something uniting
them and that's something that at this
point Hegel doesn't use the word
alienation but we are in fact alienated
estranged from this absolute moral
consciousness aren't we so he says a
specific duty on account of the actual
doing which is a specific action is also
necessary so it's not just necessity in
the sense of the necessity imposed upon
us by pure duty thou shalt thou shalt
not sort of abstract it away from any
content I mean think about the Decalogue
as the you know prime example of this it
doesn't say listen I'm God and I've got
one simple rule for you you will do your
duty you know people look at me what the
hell are our duties then okay I know I'm
supposed to fulfill them but can you
give me a little hint about what I'm
supposed to do
and then you've got some very general
broad outlines that have been debated
for you know centuries after centuries
well you notice bearing false witness is
that just in a law court or does that
apply the lying in general is it okay
for me to not tell the truth if I if I'm
not actually outright lying you know
people get into all sorts of you know
niceties about this but that's dealing
with more specific content you might
think about the you know revaluation of
some of the other Commandments
you know but you know thou shalt not
kill or murder right and then you get
this this guy later on saying well you
know the losses that the Decalogue says
that but I'm also saying if you get
angry with your brother you're doing
something wrong along those same lines
you know and so these specific duties
they can become quite quite vast can't
they and they're necessary Hegel says
they are necessary why why do we have to
have specific duties this is well we
just have to apply it to something we
need some sort of material in order to
make sense out of this this pure idea
know they confront us equally as things
incumbent upon us as a zoeland that you
know you ought to write or in latin as a
debonair a or in greek day you must
there is a de ontological binding force
even with them so he says it's necessity
what what's necessity of specific duties
necessity falls outside of that
consciousness the consciousness of pure
duty into another consciousness now
which other consciousness this is the
thing to think about is that the
consciousness of the average person who
not even average person every person
insofar as they exist whether they're a
beggar or a king right insofar as they
have any real duties in the real world
to real persons or about real things
those are specific duties and they have
to treat them as necessary or they have
to break the duty
there is this other consciousness the
ruler of the world who could do in fact
what Hegel's talking about mediating
bringing together the specific and pure
duty and is the reason why the former
the specific has validity the question
is do we really really need to postulate
this or can we in fact become that other
without becoming the ruler of the world
Hegel's not actually broaching that
question here because he's just
following along moral consciousness as
it develops it's going to write wind up
in a bit of a bind towards the end of
this section but you will see that
coming as we get into the next paragraph
in the actual doing however
consciousness behaves as this particular
self as completely individual it is
directed towards reality as such and has
this for its purpose for it wills to
achieve something duty in general this
falls outside of it into another being
which is consciousness and the sacred
lawgiver of pure duty for the
consciousness which acts and just
because it acts the validity of the
other consciousness that of pure duty is
directly acknowledged this pure Duty is
thus the content of another
consciousness and is sacred for the
consciousness that acts only immediately
that is through the agency of this other
consciousness
here in this short paragraph 607 Hegel's
telling us a little bit more about these
two consciousnesses that we were
discussing in the previous paragraph one
of which here he's actually going to
call the sacred law giver hiding against
Gaber all right who is essentially God
right conceived of as a moral being and
he tells us that in the actual doing in
the condom or comportment if you like
it's not just a ton doing an action it's
it's a particular way of behaving
consciousness he says behaves as this or
it relates itself as this particular
self as completely individual or as in
other words like a fulfilled individual
Ang's illness he says now here's a very
interesting observation it's directed at
reality as such as its purpose or end or
goal what does that mean in in action in
doing things whether it's duty-bound or
not we are actually engaging in reality
even if it's an interior reality like if
I'm willing myself to think about some
particular matter or to remember where I
left my keys I'm working on reality and
I'm trying to do something all thinking
is in some sense practically motivated
if not necessarily practical there's an
end or goal in place very often many
complex systems of ends or goals or
purposes and we direct ourselves at
reality as an end or goal in two
different ways we you can talk about as
Freud did the reality principle man if
you don't take account of the way things
actually are whatever great intentions
you have or whatever pipe dreams you
have about realizing your pleasures are
gonna
come smack against the the pain and the
obstacles and the setbacks that you're
going to face and ultimately death to
death and loss there's that but there's
also this drive to impose something on
reality reality is almost like a l'heure
that draws us to modify it to contribute
to it and it's doing both of these at
the same time it's conditioning what we
can act what we can expect what we can
act upon and it's also drawing us in to
act upon it so he says it's directed
towards reality as such has this for its
purpose why because it wills to achieve
to produce something what is it trying
to produce whatever it is that the
specific Duty is asking for it so if
it's to save for my children's education
that means that the ha1
must include making some money not
spending that money finding a safe place
to put that money that's part of the
reality that I'm dealing with and to
produce a reality in which that money
exists at the end of the day when
they're going to college and we could go
on and on with all sorts of other
examples so what about duty in general
what about duty as such he says it falls
outside of it into what another being
now what's this other being well we saw
in the previous paragraph there has to
be this ruler of the world that's the
notion that's uniting all these
different aspects of moral consciousness
that is you know postulating the harmony
of nature and and morality or happiness
and morality all this other stuff here
Hegel talks in terms of the holy or
divine law giver or Norm creator you
might say he says this is a
consciousness and the sacred lawgiver of
pure Duty the one who is telling us what
duty in general consists in
so then he says the consciousness which
acts just because it acts the validity
of the other consciousness that of pure
duty is directly acknowledged when when
we're acting in accordance with duty
we're not saying I only have these
specific duties screw the general
conception of duty no we see our are
fulfilling our specific duties as in
fact somehow in some distant way
realizing or participating in this
greater capital D Duty this Duty in
general so when I you know act as a
dutiful father and try to save for my
kids college education I'm not just
doing that one thing although it's very
easy to start losing track of that in
which case it no longer becomes a moral
duty and just becomes a purely pragmatic
thing right but I still want to retain
that connection to duty as a whole or I
might think of my duty as a professor to
my students right should I actually show
up the first day of class prepared to
teach and have a syllabus in hand these
are very prosaic duties and you can say
well what's going to happen if you don't
well I'm not going to prepare my
students for a good semester that's a
specific duty that ties in with greater
Duty so when we're doing our specific
duties we are one of the end goals is to
actually fulfill duty writ large now
here's where it gets really interesting
he's got this little offhand remark here
this pure Duty is the content of another
consciousness and it's sacred for the
consciousness that acts only immediately
through the agency of this other
consciousness so we've got another
consciousness other consciousness what's
going on here who's acting mediated ly
well in a certain way both of them are
acting mediated ly but one of them is
being referred to here as acting
immediately the sacred law giver doesn't
act directly within the cosmos within
reality
the sacred law giver acts through each
of us fulfilling our specific duties
at the same time our specific duties are
duties by participating or in some way
expressing or being connected to this
broader conception of duty and we need
both sides of this we can't reduce one
to the other although people have often
tried in their reconstructions of
morality
you